- This is COP 326, "Elevating Application
and Generative AI Observability".
My name is Matheus Arrais.
I'm a worldwide tech lead for CloudOps,
based of Dallas, Texas.
This is my sixth re:Invent.
I'm very excited to be
here. I have Peter with me.
- Hi, I'm Peter Geng.
I'm product manager in
CloudWatch, my first re:Invent.
We're very excited to meet you as well.
- Awesome. So, let's
start with this picture.
So, imagine if you were in a store,
like if you're driving
down the unfamiliar highway
and you have very limited
visibility, so it's quite
nervous-racking and dangerous as well.
You don't know what exactly
what's the roads are gonna do
or what's gonna appear in front of you
and you're just starting to grip
the steering wheel even harder.
Your palms are sweating.
You just wanna make sure
they're drive safe home.
We all be in, you know,
this familiar situation,
driving with limited visibility
and we don't wish it to repeat it again.
So, this is like operating
in today's complex
applications powered by AI.
We often lack of visibility
and observability
and you just wanted to understand
how the systems are driving forward
and without it, it's quite dangerous.
Even our CTO Verna Vogues, he once said
that you needed to have observability
because without it, you are just guessing.
You are guessing what the
system's gonna do next,
how the systems will react to the dynamics
of your end users.
So, in this presentation,
we're gonna help with that.
First of all, I'm gonna understand how
application observability
monitoring is today.
What are the challenge that you have now
that we have generative AI
in place and how that comes
and play Along with that,
how to gain visibility
and observability to
AI power applications.
So, our commitment, myself and Peter,
that you're gonna walk from this session,
going back to your places, your homes
with actionable insights for
how you elevate application,
but also generative observability
in a single pane of glass.
Let's start with John. So,
John, here is our persona.
So, he's a SRE, he's a developer.
He's someone that is using
CloudWatch in a daily basis.
And as you can see,
his application right
there is quite complex.
There is many layers.
That's backhand, database,
infrastructure layer.
So, John's using just
the simple monitoring,
like CPU metric, stuff like that.
There is many layers on that application
that John can leverage, as
you can see on this diagram.
So, each layer that you see on the screen
is a possible layer
that it can be observed.
So, networking,
infrastructure, application,
database, users and so on.
From the bottom up,
AWS offers many choice
for you, for instance,
on the infrastructure.
So, you can observe on
the ECU perspective,
containers perspective,
serverless, on-prems, and so on.
Application layer, which
is one of the crucial ones
because you can use
application logs to understand
how the application
traces the interconnection
between your applications,
moving from the CPU metric perspective
to a service-level, objective
perspective, time backed
to your business outcome.
Last but not least, you
have the user perspective
where you can create understanding
of your user behavior
and using CloudWatch for that.
So, what John have asked for us,
it is I wanted a native integration
because he's using AWS today.
He wanted faster time to attack problems
and also to resolve them.
You want it to cost
optimize, doesn't want it
to move data from here to there.
You know, doing deduplication,
this is quite complex.
And also, it should be
a single pane of glass.
Should be a simple service to use
that has actionable inside.
It is smart.
It's using, for instance, machine learning
to understand anomaly.
And for each one of those layers,
Amazon CloudWatch offers
John a perspective
and an option to monitor his
application cover to cover.
So, from the bottom up in the internet,
in network perspective,
we have for instance,
internet monitoring, can
analyze internet performance
understanding if it is also your
internet provider has problems on outages.
You have the infrastructure
level, the blue one,
where you can have a CPU
container service, some prints
and you can leverage containers
insights, lambda insights
to understand the system level
of that particular infrastructure choice.
We have database insights, too
to collect monitor database
performance in the real time
so you can leverage,
understand which SQL queries
is taking longer than others.
The green one, which is
the application leverage
is the most crucial
one like I said before,
because you can automatically
detect your KPIs,
your application KPIs
and use SLOs to maintain
server quality commitments
that you have with your customers.
Last but not least, the top level,
which the user's perspective
you can use run real user
monitoring and synthetics to
produce canaries to simulate
what the user's behavior in an alert,
if you have any availability issues
or performance degradation,
all that in a single tool,
which is Amazon CloudWatch.
So, going to the three
pillars of observability,
everyone might be familiar with this,
but that's the journey that
we wanted to discuss here.
Every monitor observability strategy
will come along with
metrics, logs and traces.
This is a call as a three
pillars of observability.
Metrics, it is, I wanted to understand,
I have the information
that my application response
latest increased 35%.
Logs, I have the information
in the data structure
or not a structure that, you know,
my authentication user just
authentication my application.
And trace, I can ask questions
or answer questions about
distribution processing time
of my microservice across the board.
So, as you saw it in the
beginning, John has a quite
complex architecture.
And then, of course some
challenge also arises with that.
Microservice, like a complex
architecture needs constantly
performancy over time
to satisfy the end user.
You have also John needs
to manually teach together telemetry data
with the service to
understand the degradation
of availability and high latency.
Also, it's very hard to
understand what is the priority
for the business, right?
Understand those anomaly,
which ones matter most
to the business and how he
should prioritize with that.
Last, but not least, this joint experience
because correlating that telemetry data
from the perspective of metrics, logs
and traces, you also needed
to put in place real user monitoring,
synthetics monitoring.
If you put it that all
together, that can extend it
in a very long time to
attack the real issue.
Now, in order to offer a
technical perspective how John
should use and what he should use
and look specifically
for elevate his monitoring,
it is the golden signals.
So, the golden signals
are volume requests,
which is directly impact
the demand in place
of your application directly
impact also in latency.
Latency is speed, right?
How much time a specific
request expand to be resolved.
And for that, if you have high latency
or you also have the directly impacting
the user's experience,
The two in the bottom,
you have fault and errors.
This is a tieback to requests.
There are mold form or application issues.
So, you needed to
understand those in order
to understand your application
monitor as another level.
Now, this is a technical perspective.
What John needed to do
here, it is also to connect
that from the business perspective, right?
So, for instance,
business impacts directly
to revenue per minute
or if you have a car abdomen,
what is the level of that?
What is the user experience signal?
For instance, page load time,
what is the API errors code
and session duration, so on and so forth?
You have service health
indicators like latency, P90, P95.
You wanted to understand
that particular piece
to understand the overall health.
And last but not least,
connecting with availability
objectives, tying back each signal
with an SLO, a service
level object to ensure
that you're maintaining the optimal
level of the application.
So, in order to answer those questions,
you know, John should focus
on that particular layer
because on that layer it's
where John can tie back
all those knots, all those
dots, the application level.
And, Amazon offer an APM solution
called Amazon CloudWatch
Application Signals.
From using Application Signals,
John can elevate his
application monitoring
because, first of all,
that is Application Signals
automatically discover
which applications you
have in your account,
using OpenTelemetry SDK.
You don't need it to do anything, right?
It's already automatically
discover for you by CloudWatch.
Second of all, there
is pre-built dashboards
with standard metrics,
including those golden
signals will have that,
so we can understand the technical metrics
that I just mentioned a few seconds ago.
Third, you have easy understanding
with a few clicks the root
cause if you have a HTTP
malform, if you have a
deception, you can understand
where's the deception, which
line of code and so on.
Last but not least, SLO,
service link object.
So, this is related to
goals on your reliability
and tying back to the business object.
This is crucial for any
application monitoring strategy.
And that's why, when we talk
about application monitoring,
we talk about the SLOs,
because it is a
comprehensive understanding
of application health
from the user perspective,
and this is how it works.
You have an application or an
API called Gap Research API,
and I have a particular internal
goal of 99.9% of up uptime
of this particular API.
Well, in order to have that,
I already select a particular SLI,
which is service link
indicator, to measure that goal.
In this case it is uptime,
but as you see there is a 0.1%
that can create something
called error budget,
which meaning if I'm
evaluating this particular SLO
in a 30-days period, I
still have 43 minutes
of downtime and still meet my SLO.
Why is this important?
Because you can tie all
this back with your SLA
and SLA, everyone know,
is agreement that you do
with your customers.
So, when you put it in the perspective,
what are you gonna have?
You're gonna have happy customers
because if you are looking
for all those APIs,
establishing all those SLOs,
tying back to the SLIs,
customers are able to understand
that you take care of the application.
In this particular case,
John will achieve happy end users, too.
Okay, so let's go for the
demo. Let's go to the fun part.
In this demo I'm gonna show
specifically two scenarios
of fault and also latency problems
that I have in my application
and how we can use Application Signals
to monitor my entire
application observability
in a single console.
So, first of all, what I'm
gonna do it is to show SLOs.
So, I have multiple SLOs,
as you can see here,
and some of them, of
course, are unhealthy.
I wanted to show how to create an SLO.
SLO can be...
I needed to choose first the SLI.
SLI can be a service operation
and CloudWatch metric
or a service dependency.
And again, that service
means that, you know,
is automatically discovered
by OpenTelemetry SDK in this case I'm,
I'm gonna use my frontend,
PetClinic frontend
and a specific operation of posts.
And the interesting part,
right now I can select
the calculation method
for this particular SLO,
which can be by request
or by period and I can
select also the condition
of the particular calculation method,
that can be either by
latency, I'm choosing
100 milliseconds right
now and also availability.
One of the cool things
it is CloudWatch put
that little phrase over there,
which is exactly the terms
what I'm doing, you know
in the configuration.
From that, I select what is my SLO.
I define my interval of period
that will be assessed by this
SLO, the attainment goal.
And also I have the
little phrase over there.
Of course, none of this makes sense
if I don't tie backs alarms.
Alarms can be directly related to the SLI
or the SLO attainment goal
and the overall health of this SLO.
Everything there, it makes
sense for that particular API.
Now, I wanted to show also something
beyond which is application mac.
We launched this like
a couple of weeks ago.
This is what I mentioned
related to auto discovery
from the OpenTelemetry
perspective, not just instrumented
but also uninstrumented application
capable to be discovered
by application map.
I can filter by groups.
There's multiple filters
that I can select over here.
And then, all the applications
that I have in this account
will automatically be select
on those little boxes
on the right hand side.
Even if I wanted to create
my own custom attribute,
I can use configurations
directly on OpenTelemetry config
file and will show up directly
here on the console, too.
Now, going a little bit
deeper on the PetClinic
that I mentioned, when
I click double click,
I see the total polish.
So, this is my total
polish from my application.
All the connections that
I have with the frontend,
with the backend, all
the, the microservice
that I have connections I can see.
And if I click on the fin line, I'm able
to see the interconnection
between one server to the other
and understand the top
path with fault rate
with high latency, so on and so forth.
If I click in that particular
frontend back again,
what I have on the right end
signs, it is the golden signals
that I mentioned before.
So, requests, volume
requests, latency, arrows
and faults are out out of the gate for me.
Over there I can enlarge
to see this over the time
and select P90, P99 or P50.
And, one of the cool things
that I believe here
that CloudWatch gives it
is this operational auditing.
So, as you can see, I have
some drops, some spikes,
so CloudWatch already
given to me over there.
What did the indication
that the problem should be?
So, what exactly happen
in that period of time
and exactly what's gonna happen,
you know, needed to assess even further.
So, to assess even further,
when I click in the dashboard,
I can see the overall metrics
for this particular application.
And again, metrics,
all the golden signals
are here, as you can see,
but one of the things that I
mentioned in the SLO creation,
it is the service operation.
So, using OpenTelemetry, I'm able
to understand all the
posts, the gaps, the puts
that these applications
using behind the things
and understand, as you can see,
I have SLIs that are unhealthy.
If I double click in the dashboard
because I have a spike of a fault,
it will automatically show
the correlation of spans
that it's necessary for
that request to be served.
And if I click in one of those spans,
it will show me exactly
what is the trace map
from the frontend to the backend,
what exactly the whole trace
and the spans for this
request to be resolved.
And, I can even see
the same visualization,
but now in a timeline perspective,
in a span timeline perspective,
where is this host?
And as you can see, there is
a fault in the visit service.
Java is throwing an exception
and exception, it is a
DynamoDB throughput problem.
I can see the message
and also the line, specifically the line
that in my code I needed to
go back and fix the problem.
And, even in the DynamoDB perspective,
I can see the message on
the right hand side, too.
One of the interesting part, if I go back
to the previous dashboard, I can also see
because this is the EKS
cluster, where is the node
that is having most problems
with this particular fault
and what exactly are the pods
that are having this pod?
And then, I can prioritize
by looking to these nodes and pods.
Even if I click to container insights
on this little button is is
gonna guide me to a console
where I can see my container insights
performance across the board.
This is in the single pane of glass.
So, dependencies is
another tab on on, again,
same application that I can
see all the dependence related
to this application and also, of course,
the dependence related to the service.
So, this is the second use case
that I talk about latency.
So, as you can see there is
a spike in this specific time
and I'm just gonna click on one
of the traces using the same
methodology on the previous
use case, but now looking for latency.
And, you're gonna see that now,
because it's a different API
that I have high latency,
it's being served for
different service including,
for instance, Bedrock.
I have the same visualization trace map
and also the timeline with all the Spans`.
And as you can see,
the Bedrock runtime has an
arrow, specifically when I click
into view, it will show me exactly
what the section is being
throw in the MyCode.
In this case, the problem is
the Bedrock foundation model
is being deprecated.
So, that's why I have high latency
because it's been deprecated.
So, it's taking too much
time to be resolved back
to my user and even if I click
in the event, I'll be able
to see that more properly.
Now, this is the application level.
I wanted to also show the
user that top level layer.
You can use synthetics canaries to create
and simulate user's behavior.
In this case of our percentage
on you can create to simulate
what exactly steps that needs to be used
and simulate what is what a user will use
his applications for.
And we'll take little screenshots
as well if you determine to do so.
You can also use the user experience,
the run that I mentioned before,
to understand page load
if there any arrows.
You can see when I increase the time
on the right hand side, I
can see the arrows over time,
understand what exactly the page
that I have from the user perspective
that are having the problems
with load specifically,
and when I click one of this,
that's giving me the entire
information regarding
that particular error.
And, this is a user perspective,
so, I need, and I can see
when the session happened,
when this happened,
which type of browser
CloudWatch used to simulate
the user behavior
and I can, you know, understand
my user experience across the board.
Now, this is the application part
and now I wanted to move over to the genAI
because now John, Peter needs
to include genAI in his application.
Yes, thank you so much, Matheus.
- I'm so excited here to talk to you about
how observability has changed
to monitored AI workloads.
So, raise your hand if
you are currently building
an AI application or
workload in your company.
Okay, wow, most of the room,
so you're in the right place.
So, looking back this
crazy year, this 2025,
we all know that AI-powered application
is gonna transform the
way that your business
and your end users interact
with your business.
Every tech leader here is
seeing in real time how easy
and powerful it is to build
these AI workloads on AWS.
So, I'm here to help you navigate
through this time in a
lens from observability
and showing you three things.
Number one, how observability has changed
and the new tools that you can use.
And second, how
observability is still some
of the same things that
you're already familiar with
and show you the existing
tools that you can use.
And lastly, showing all
that together with a demo
of that workload.
So, walking back in memory
lane, so we started this AI talk
back when we had these
question and answer chat bots,
but that is so 2023.
What we then had, these are AI assistants,
or what kind of the AI entity
that walks the user step
by step, step through a
particular business process.
But now today, what we have is AI agents.
These entities are more autonomous
that can do certain tasks
by themselves and make
decisions independently
to achieve specific goals.
What we think in the future
will be is fully agentic systems
where the entire systems
behave independently,
achieve open-ended requests and goals
and help the entire business
make its own decision
and drive those outcomes.
And how do you even build
these AI applications?
In AWS we offer a full
stack of tools for you
to build those workloads.
And, monitoring is
across the entire stack.
Starting from the bottom, can
help you build, run, train
and deploy those AI models on SageMaker
and also on our infrastructure.
And the middle layer I think
is gonna be the meat of it,
it's gonna be first is the Amazon Bedrock,
which is a fully managed
service that offers you
direct access to a slew
of foundation models
through a single API.
So, you can scale up your
application really easily.
And then the more recently
launched AgentCore,
where's the place for you to build
and deploy highly scalable
and capable AI agents.
It comes with a suite of
tools to augment those agent
with memory so the agent knows
the context, with gateway
so the agent has control over what kind
of third party APIs it calls
and identity for
authentication and control.
And going higher, even in AWS
we've used these things
to build up those fully
agentic systems with
Kiro, the agentic IDE,
Q, agentic business intelligence
and also Amazon connected
with agentic contact
center have been loved
with millions of customers.
So, wherever, however you're building AI,
we've got you covered.
And again, in every layer
observability is there with you.
Now, here comes the question is how do you
have the right observability
on these AI applications?
How do you see, how do you
track what the AI is doing?
And then what's new, what's different?
So, let me help you navigate
through this rapidly changing time.
With these AI application,
what we've talked to customers
and they've unanimously come back to us
with some common challenges.
Number one, these agents
can be indeterministic.
Their actions can defer from time to time,
even from similar past
scenarios is very unexpected.
They're like teenagers.
Sometimes they say brilliant things,
sometimes you wish they
didn't say anything at all.
And second, root cause
analysis is focused on tracking
the sequence of calls
that the agents made,
but it's very difficult to trace.
Analyzing those invocations
at scale is very difficult
because every model provider
has a slightly different
format and tracking that volume
across different regions
accounts is harder than
it's supposed to be.
Now, so lastly is assessing system health.
It's still the same goal
that Matheus talked about,
but what's new is this
word quality, right?
Now, you need to answer
why did the agent do the thing it did?
Why did it route itself in that way?
What context did it have?
Well, sort of the
traditional monitoring tools
can tell you the performance,
surfacely performance
parameters like latency errors,
but it doesn't tell
you that the reasoning,
doesn't explain to you the
AI decision making process.
So, you are no longer just
observing whether your AI
is working or not going up or down,
but you're trying to observe
reasoning and intent.
And we believe this will be
your new operational reality.
Observability is going
to be the control plane
for trust, safety and quality.
Now, going back to the same stack layer
that Matheus showed you,
we believe that AI workload is gonna ride
on top of all of this.
And, observability is there is going
to be operating at the highest
level with you as well,
connecting from all the way
from the infrastructure signals,
stitching the telemetry
throughout, throughout the stack
and coalescing from those
different models, agent actions
to observe the entire
end-to-end interaction for you.
That's why from those
challenges we worked,
that was introduced to you,
Amazon genAI observability
already in GA has a slew
of capabilities.
Number one is a 360-degree
view of your agent no matter
what model they're using on frameworks
such as Strands, Strands,
CrewAI, LangChain
and with out of the box dashboards
on those performance parameters.
Second is very simple to
instrument your your AI workload
as long as using OTel, which
is OpenTelemetry format.
We'll touch on that a little bit later.
And, very importantly is the
end-to-end prompt tracing
which traces across the LLM calls,
the agent actions, the tools,
the memory calls it makes for you
to quickly identify issues.
And, in the data protection world,
now, in these AI interactions,
it is very likely
that what the AI receives
or the AI outputs can contain PI content
and those are stored in the logs
and we have data
protection features to mask
that content and protect it.
And lastly is the evaluations feature
for you to monitor the quality.
And these are using LLM as
a judge to constantly assess
how your AI is responding,
whether it's saying the right things,
whether it's routing itself correctly
and solving your customer problems.
And, to build these agents is fairly easy
on AWS AgentCore.
AgentCore allows you to deploy,
operate highly capable AI
agents securely at scale.
It offers infrastructure purpose built
for these dynamic agent workloads.
As you can tell, it coalesced
from different aspects
of what the agent would use.
For example, any model, LLM
model offered on Bedrock
and they will use AgentCore memory,
which is the context of polls,
and uses to operate identity,
controls the security,
and also gateway, which
is a central place for it
to make third party API
tool calls and all that.
And as you can see all the tools
and the primitives around
the agent sent telemetry
to the observability platform,
which is CloudWatch observability.
So, you can have that single pane of glass
to monitor all of this.
One thing I do wanna
highlight has been resonating
with a lot of our customers
is that you can host
your agents on AgentCore runtime service
and that telemetry comes
through CloudWatch.
You can get all the features
that talked about out the box.
Also if you're coasting your
agents elsewhere, EC2, AKS,
on-prem or other clouds, as long
as your data is in an OTel
format, we can also accept it
and you'll get very similar capabilities
in CloudWatch as well.
So, giving you that flexibility
wherever fits your needs.
Going to a little bit
deeper on the agents running
on AgentCore runtime, when creating
and running these agents,
we provide even more flexibility
on how you create them.
We support Gentech frameworks
like very popular ones,
Strands Agents, CrewAI, LangChain,
and support of instrumentation libraries
are already brought are all open source,
open inference, trace loop.
And once you've been
instrumented connected
with the Amazon distro
for OpenTelemetry, ADOT
and we collect that
instrumentations, send it
to the CloudWatch OTel endpoint,
and we will be powering those
screens that I talked about
before or specifically
agents hosted on runtime,
remember that ADOT I talked about?
Plus once all of that
telemetry is coming in,
in a CloudWatch telemetry
config with a single click,
you can turn on all of the telemetry
from those individual primitives
like AgentCore memory,
AgentCore gateway in a single click
from entire account.
All that comes to CloudWatch
and power those views
and for agents have hosted elsewhere,
Still the ADOT, but I need to emphasize
that as long as in the OTel
format, we also accept it
and turn on CloudWatch Transaction
Search to stitch together
those actions and tool calls
it talked about in there.
And, here's a very, very
easy quick start guide.
You can even start it working on it
right now on your laptop.
So, with all that groundwork
we laid, let's focus
on what John's doing
with his genAI workloads
in more practical terms.
Here, I think this slide
looks very similar to you
of what you saw before,
and you already know it,
it's the metrics, the logs
and the traces and that's still powering
the genAI observability.
That's the same old
tools you've using today.
So with metrics, these things
are like the token consumption
and you're tracking
how those have changed,
the volume of work the AI has done.
Well, the logs is where you
keep those verbose inputs
and outputs from the user
and from the outputs of the
LLM models and the agents.
And lastly, tracing, very important.
The traces now can understand
how the response propagates
through the entire system
and you can analyze it
at the aggregate level
and you have the capability
to drill down on every single interaction.
Okay, little bit more detail
on how it really works.
Metrics, these are some common metrics
you'll be able to monitor
on is number of invocations,
how fast these invocations
are completing itself,
any throttles and the volume
work like InputTokenCounts,
OutputTokenCounts, and the logs
coming from the model invocation, logging,
and also the span logs which
contain each individual step
and the contents of any tool
calls and the agent's actions.
And lastly, the trace, as long
as it contains the same
session ID or trace ID
and stitch together
will be able to surface
the end-to-end interaction
that I talked to you about before.
And with those, on the metrics,
we've put it into the
same set of golden metrics
that we believe you should be monitoring.
In the first bucket is the
token usage, the volume of work
that AI is doing and help
you to not only forecast
the demand that you'll have and also cost.
And then, latency, how fast is your AI
responding to your needs?
Throttles to keep a track
about how close you're going
against your limits and quotas.
And, errors, seeing anything
that's going wrong in your request.
And we'd be able to show
surface all these things
in a prebuilt automatic dashboard
without any configuration.
So, you can diagnose,
troubleshoot from here.
Additional filters include
filtering by the model itself
so you can deep down into any
specific model you're using,
anything going wrong there.
And also is definitely fully integrated
with existing CloudWatch capabilities,
like alerting if you wanted
to keep track of your
total consumption patterns.
Now, here's something that's
going to be a very different,
relatively new concept to
the world of observability
that is relevant in AI.
Now, like I said before,
the new operational reality
for you is going to be
looking at the quality
of those AI responses and agent actions.
So, often these LLMs hallucinates
or the agents take on a path
all of its own that's not desired.
And in the past, how teams
have kept an eye on this,
on this qualitative issue
is the science teams
take a very small sample
of the AI workloads,
manually look at it and assess it,
and only when that's as good,
they're just okay with deploying
the AI out in the real
world, almost hesitating
and timid about what
it's really going to do.
So, these lack trust
and also very burdensome
in the entire process.
So, that's why with evaluations,
well you can leverage LLM
as a judge to assess how faithful an agent
is adhering to his context,
how well it follows
instructions you've given it
and how helpful it was
in helping your customers
achieve their tasks and questions.
And, this is done continuously
automatically on the entire
traffic of your AI workload
and you have the ability
to sample on full sampling
or only a proportion of the samples.
So, really removes the labor intensive
and manual assessment process
that our customer teams used to do.
So, evaluations metrics
was just launched yesterday
and it's available now in CloudWatch,
powered by AgentCore evaluations.
We talked about the metrics side of things
coming back into the logs.
Some of my favorite because
this is the most densely packed
information they'll be using.
I'm going to be talking
about the invocation logs,
how to query on them and
protecting that data.
So, the invocation logs can come
from both the LLM model
itself and also the agents.
You can choose to come
to a CloudWatch or S3
and once it's in CloudWatch
it's stored in the familiar
CloudWatch log groups
concept that you can use
integrated with your existing workflows.
And once those logs are in CloudWatch,
you can use the CloudWatch log insights
to drill down deeper, which
is a powerful querying tool.
We support powerful languages
like SQL, OpenSearch, PPL
and launching powerful
query commands regularly.
And you can use pattern analysis
to detect common text
structures within the log events
for faster insights and
also automated real-time
anomaly detection to identify changes
in these agent behaviors
and performance changes.
And then I said before,
these inter-customer interaction
can contain PII information
and we've got you covered when
those logs are in CloudWatch.
The CloudWatch data protection
feature can identify
and mask sensitive customer information,
like credit cards, names, addresses,
and put basically redacted for you.
Also, we offer granular
IAM role-based controls
so that if a super user needs
to see the content, they can,
but most users won't be able to.
And, we generate automatic audit reports
for compliance and reporting.
Now, coming back to the last
part, we talked about metrics,
we've talked about logs and
we're talking about traces now.
This is probably the most important part
in the genAI observability.
With tracing, the first
thing we'll be able to do
for you is show you the
detailed information
of the every single individual API call
and the function calls that agents made
in a very neat list view.
You no longer need to query
on them on multiple databases
to stitch them together.
It's done for you.
And second, we'll show you
those actions in a timeline view
so you can know, hey, which
one's taking the longest,
so which one's taking
longer than I expect for you
to troubleshoot faster.
And, a trajectory map
showing you all those
different interactions,
API calls tool calls for
this particular trace.
And, each step here is a span
and aggregated to this trace.
This map is automatically
visualized for you.
So, you can easily understand
the hierarchy and the sequence
of those tool calls in a very
easy to understand fashion.
Now, I talked about what's
different, what's the same,
the logs, metrics, and traces.
So, it's a lot.
Let's tie it all back
together with a short demo.
- Okay, let's go to the demo part, then.
So, in this demo now
we're gonna see kind of
the PetClinic that I showed before,
but now in the general
observability use case.
And, this is a perspective
of an agile administrator
or a manager that is, you know, using
a fully SHAFT agent that
is hosted by AgentCore.
And then behind the scenes
there is multiple microservice
that you saw that before.
This is the same old John's application,
so you have database
and so on and so forth.
So, here I'm just typing a
couple of prompts related
to this PetClinic.
And, this particular
prompt here, you know,
it is showing me like information
related to the owner ID.
As you can see there will be
some PI information as Peter before.
This, of course, is an
agent that's been used
for administrator perspective.
And in this last prompt it is related
to a billing information for
this patient ID number one.
And, what you're gonna see is
the agent will not be able
to capture that information
to flash that information
for some reasons.
Now this is of course, it is the frontend.
Let's go and actually see in the console.
So, first of all,
in the left front side
on Amazon CloudWatch,
you're gonna see a new section
called genAI observability.
And, this is the modeling
vocation that Peter showed before.
You have that genAI golden signals
for invocation, latency, and so on.
And all the invocations
that you have in the foundation
model, you'll be able
to either filter, query them
in CloudWatch logging site
and also, see the whole JSON file.
You can even filter by model IDs
that probably are using multiple different
foundation model that you can also see.
Now, going to the Bedrock
AgentCore, not just
for the runtime, but
CloudWatch, also observe
other parts of AgentCore, too.
So, a memory, a gate and so on.
Here, focus on the agent
runtime, specifically.
I have three agents.
I see all the overall information
regarding these agents,
how many sessions, how many traces.
Going deeper in the PetClinic
because it's the one that I'm using,
I wanted to show a couple
of informations here.
In this Overview tab,
I have out of the gate information related
to the evaluation.
So, I'm using evaluations
and I can see the evaluations score
and also configuration metric.
I can see the arrow in
latent by span specifically,
and I have this table.
As you can see, there is many
errors related to the DynamoDB
and I can, you know, see that information,
of course, double click it if I need it.
Scrolling a little bit down,
see still on the overview page
I see the how many sessions
this agent had, how many traces,
and also token consumption, very important
for cost optimization
and how AWS charge you,
it's information that is useful.
Again, how many (indistinct)
determines has and the latency,
everything that you're seeing,
it is already prebuilt for you.
Last but not least was the
CPU and memory utilization.
Now, each interaction with the agent,
it creates sessions and
session contained traces
and traces contains spans.
So, going deeper on the session part,
just reduce the time for five minutes.
So, capture the last prompt that I did
and what I can see it is kind of
the same information that I have.
But now looking for just
for this particular session.
So, it's allow you to go deeper
on this particular prompt.
If I click one of those
traces, what I can see
out of the gate, it is
how many spans latency,
token consumption. if I have any errors,
I already see one of the errors.
Remember that I was not
able to flash that data.
I also see the trajectory
of this whole prompt cover took cover,
what exactly the agent had to do in order
to produce the information backed
and all the tools that the
agent have to call on my behalf.
I'm able to see also the expense
in the format of a timeline
tree and also in the timeline,
here I'm showing the token consumption
on that particular
invocation input and output.
And this is this same visualization,
but now in a timeline perspective.
So, as you can see, I have
multiple ways to understand
how this particular session's doing.
Looking for the event itself, here is
where I will be able to see
the prompt that I did, right?
It is trying to get
information regarding payment
and then a two internally
will be a trigger.
And then what is gonna happen,
because that information
is in a DynamoDB table,
the agent doesn't have permission.
So, it is throwing an exception,
access denied exception over there
because the agent itself
doesn't have a permission
to flash that information.
That's why I was not able to see
that information on the agent.
So, here, in order to fix it, I needed to,
of course go in the IAM role of the agent
and give her permission to do so.
Now, I wanted to show,
because we mentioned related
to evaluations, right?
I have a elements, a
judge in front of this
particular agent and then just
gonna change the time here
to 12 hours to cover how many
sampling information was used
to analyze by this LLM.
And first of all, I can see the evaluation
configuration across the board.
So, filtering, it is available
and I can see like
related to stereotyping,
to session and so on and so forth.
So, each evaluation is offered
that same granularity
session, trace and spans, too.
So, as you can see, all the tracings
that I have in this particular
agents, it is right there,
and I can filter by many, many options
that is being used by the evaluator.
I also have the dashboards, right?
Dashboards, building dashboards
created by CloudWatch.
So, each one of those
elements, those metrics
that is being used by the
evaluator, it is right here.
So, instruction follow,
if the LLM used the
instruction that I gave,
if it's harmful, if it is
helpful, if it is stereotyping,
all that information, it is right here.
So, I can understand the
agent behavior itself,
and of course I have
that as in a log format
to using CloudWatch logs.
I just wanna go back to the demo
and to the session specifically
to show one last case, one
last use case going back
to the same session,
but now one of the prompts
that I did, if you remember,
was related to getting information
for an specific honor.
And again, I'm gonna have
all their information
related to the trace,
but I wanted to show, because
I have data protection rule in
place for my CloudWatch
and that that specific rule is masking
birth dates and also telephone numbers.
As you can see it will be
masked in the logs too,
right, directly here on the console.
So, we're closing to our session today,
so I wanted to make sure you
leave with a few key takeaways.
So, first of all, getting started today,
enhancing like your observability stack.
as you saw in the first demo
and also in the first part,
we talk about application monitoring.
You can use APM to help you
enhance your overall application,
understanding more the
interconnection, the dependencies
that you have in application.
Can use a application map, for instance,
to see the topology of your application
and is automatically
discovered using OpenTelemetry.
Second of all, you are building agents.
You should build agents and use CloudWatch
and genAI observability
to overall understand
and observe your agents.
If they are hosted by AgentCore or not,
you can still use CloudWatch
genAI observability
and fully integrate it
with Amazon CloudWatch.
And use the assessor,
the evaluators assess
programmatically your
agents using the evaluator.
We just launched that two days ago.
So, set up the evaluation
in order to understand your overall
instruction following for your agents.
And, you have all that in
the single pane of class.
Last but not least, I
wanted to give a couple
of resource QR codes here that is useful.
The first one it is demos, demo codes.
We have demos in the GitHub available,
not just on on BedRock AgentCore,
but also agents hosted in EKS, ECS, EC2.
The QR code in the middle
has all the links related
to AWS Observability
So, we host a show in a YouTube channel
called "The Cloud Operations Show"
that we talk about observability
collaboration as a whole.
We have workshop, best practice.
Everything that I mentioned,
it is in that single
QR code in the middle.
The last, but not the
least, the third one,
it is a blog post of
this particular launch
that I just mentioned related
to generative AI observability.
If you're interested in this
topic, I wanted to invite you.
We we have a lot of kiosks
on CloudOps in the village,
in the AWS village.
And just, you know, swing
by, we have one-on-one demos,
we have SMEs across the globe.
So, if you're interested to
ask a question, you know,
myself and Peter is
gonna be there outside.
We also can answer your question,
but if you wanted to go to
the kiosk, please do so.
We have swags, we have
stickers, we can do demos.
So, just go there and
we're gonna help you.
Last, but least, I wanted to thank you,
thank you for your time.
Appreciate you come to this presentation.
I really wanted to ask you to
please complete the survey.
We use that data every year
to improve our sessions.
So, if you go to your AWS
Event app in your cell phone,
you'll be able to go to More
and then Surveys on the top.
This is COP326, so please
give your data points related
to this session so we
can improve next year.
So, with that, I wish the
best of luck to the rest
of the re:Invent and thank
you very much for being here.
Thank you.
(audience applauds)